hello everyone and welcome to game
number eighteen of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael
Thailand the Mikhail Botvinnik and
things are not looking so bright for
Mika Botvinnik tile is leading the match
by three points it's ten to seven and he
needs 12 and a half points to win the
match so he needs basically five more
draws and it's a game over
of course he will not try to draw all of
the five games he will still try to play
you know therefore advantage you would
white and try and create something with
black but Botvinnik definitely needs to
start start doing something so this game
once again a botanique is white and tall
well once again
go for the nimzo-indian defense and the
Botanic will once again try to go to go
for the night h3 variation but we'll see
what happens in this game so basically
the same variation we had in Game 16 in
game 14 here both make plays d4 again
Knight to f6 c4 e6 and Knight to c3
Bishop to b4 the names of Indian defense
a 3b captures on c3 be captures and now
the immediate Knight to e4 like we've
seen before Quincy to f5 like in
tomorrow's book Knight to h3 and now
castles in the previous game tal went d6
this is now maybe not an improvement but
just taking a slightly different path
you know we both Nick prepared something
special in regards of the last game so
here talk castles and we have f3 kicking
the knight back Knight to f6 and now c5
and the c5 was bought Phoenix
improvement on this variation because he
kind of knew that maybe Todd would go
this way but also know that botnik
already played this game and has already
played this c5 move so that was ready
for it
c5 is excellent because it kind of
prevents black from pushing b6 + b6 not
really preventing it but if you decide
to put b6 or d6 you're gonna help a
white eliminate his CC pawn so tall as
he expected this he does play b6 we have
C capture some b6 and now a cap a C
capture some b6 those who are very new
to chest might might think that why not
a capture some b6 a capture some b6 is
indeed
the better move and it's indeed the
principled move you want to capture
towards the center but it all felt that
he didn't really have any any ideas what
to do with this rook on the a file as
this this pawn on a3 has very well
protected he can probably never capture
it so he decided to go a slightly
different way and if one thing he knew
that both mean he could definitely
didn't prepare for a seek after some b6
and because this is completely you know
anti positional hardly botanique was
prepared for a variation like this
he Robotnik plays III and III is a is a
great move he doesn't fall for towels
towels little trap at the head to
immediately take the center with E for
here tal had in mind F captors on e 4f
captors on e4 and now Bishop to b7 with
a double attack on the e pawn and now
after Bishop to d3 Knight captures so
basically it seems like I'll just
randomly sacrificed a piece on e4 but
not really after Bishop captures he has
Queen to h4 check and now after the
knight blocks which is the whole point
of Knight being on h3 the knight also
defends the bishop on e4 but now simply
Bishop captures on e4 and the knight of
course is pinned if you capture with the
Queen then Queen captures here King
moves and simply Knight to c6
not allowing Queen to capture the rook
and the blacks position is much better
probably when winning whites whites
completely undeveloped and black is also
up upon so this was a palace little idea
with the seek after some be 6 but
botanique plays III so correct Queen to
c7 and now Bishop to d2 and here tall
doesn't really have an idea how to
continue developing he doesn't want to
play Bishop to a6 if you play Bishop to
a6 you're only kind of helping white and
another thing white can simply ignore
you can go Bishop d3 and then after you
capture Queen captures on d3 and this
night will not will not have too much
fun entering the game so basically he
doesn't want to do this so instead he
plays Knight to e8 nice to hear it would
with the idea of taking advantage of the
weak c4 square as there is no longer a
be pawn in white camp das idea is
something like Knight to be
followed to be seven to a five and then
from there to c4
if Botvinnik allows it of course so
immediately c4 but now now the bishop to
a6 is allowed since the the c4 pawn is
blocking the Bishop rook the c1 and now
Knight to d6 again piling up on the c4
pawn queen to a4 I'm pinning and now
Queen to c6 a table offers the trade of
Queens and here botanique accepts it but
this was also a towels towels little
trap so watch me plays Queen captures on
c6 Knight captures and we have a knight
Bishop to b4 now painting that night
kind of forcing forcing tile to capture
the bishop on b4 as you can't really
protect this Knight subbotnik thought
okay that captures I'm gonna improve my
pawn pawn structure and all is well but
this was Todd's plan knife captures pawn
captures and now Bishop captures on c4
tell us spent five minutes on this move
whether to capture with the bishop or
with the night he decided with the
bishop this is this might be something
botany missed but it might be something
hidden and who knows Bishop captures and
now rook F the c8 simply pinning that
bishop as the rook and c1 is undefended
Bishop captures on e6 giving back the
piece about grabbing a pawn pawn
captures and now kink to d2 we have King
to f7 and Knight to f4 and here you have
a the material is equal both players
have two rooks both players have two
nights every both waters have six points
but one thing you have to notice is that
tal has a majority on the Queen side and
already tells plan is very clear and he
just has to push a5 and he already
created a passed pawn on the Queen side
so blacks position might not be better
but it's definitely easier to play so
tally mmediately pushes at a 5b captures
be captures now creates a very powerful
past a pawn king to d3 and now a 4 we
have worked to captures on c8 rook
captures and now rook to a1
attacking the past pawn and here top
late night to see for this defends the
pawn with the tactic that if you capture
it Knight checks the king
and captures the rook but he didn't
really like this move later after the
game he thought that instead of this
Knight to c4 and maybe rook to e8 was a
better idea but okay Knight to c4 and
here rook to be one going for that b7
square
a3 now comes rope to b7 check King to f6
and rook to a7 now attacking the past
pawn from behind g5 would a tempo on the
knight Knight to h5 check King to g6 and
now g4 and g4 is a very interesting idea
because if you decide to play something
like a - okay regardless of the fact
that white can simply grab the pawn oh
the real threat is rook to g7 check and
after you move a rope to f7 with the
threat of rook to f6 checkmate in this
in this instance it doesn't really work
because black can simply block that but
then white can simply attack the point
once again and what white is much better
now here your opponent's attacked your
knight is attacked everything is hanging
so it would be very hard to find the
solution here for black but another
interesting thing is when I was
preparing to show you this game i
thought i'll kg4 and now i just wanted
to make a silly move to show you the
threat of rope to g7 and then i I just
you know played any move I played rook
to c6 I didn't even consider what
effects it might have on the game and
then I saw up to c6 and after this rope
to g7 check King to h6 and rook turfs
and threatening checkmate that rook
takes rook the c6 was actually a great
move because now black has a 5 rook is
guarding f6 and it's a very dangerous
position offer white you can't capture
because Knight captures will check the
King and win the rook on f7 so basically
rook to c6 would not be a silly movie it
would actually be a very nice move for
at all but okay after g4 first stop late
night the V to check King to d2 and now
Knight back to c4 check King to d3 night
the B to check King to d2 and knight
back to C for church so tal repeated a
knight C for an IB to three times if
Botvinnik repeats King to d3 it's a draw
by threefold repetition but now botanic
plays king to eat to botany did not want
to draw he does have the white pieces
and he's done three points in the match
he just wanted to save some time and get
closer to move 40 to reach time control
here rook to c6 so the move I previously
played as as a silly move we have h3 and
now e5 pawn captures and here Tao feels
that pawn captures was was Botvinnik not
going for for for for most most that he
could by playing d5 maybe maybe but it
would have more chances but again botany
as usual was in time trouble this is
moved 37 and he takes the pawn pawn
captures we have pawn captures and g4
pawn captures on g4 and now Knight
captures on e5 rook captures on a3 rook
to c2
this comes with check and here here here
this is move like I said 39 botany has
to make move 40 and he played King to f1
King to f1 with the idea that if you
play something like King d1 attack the
road and rook to f2 you lose this pawn
it's an instant draw by tau so now what
Sonique is still up a pawn and he plays
King to f1 what's the idea that now if
tall captures I'm f3 this loses the game
for tall and it's it's a very nice idea
for you to pause the video here and find
out why it loses the game so feel free
to pause and find be a bit tall in this
position so as usual I will give it a
couple of seconds so for those who found
it congratulations you you've just
beaten me kowtow and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show the
reason this losses is rook to a sex
check you have to move you can't go to
h6 you can go here this is all covered
by the night you can go here you can go
here discover by the pawn only move is
king - king to f7 and here comes Luke to
f6 check and now you see you lose the
knight King moves and ro captures on f3
so there's the reason you can't capture
it here instead of capturing top plate
King to f7 and he felt very happy about
King to f7 because he no longer had to
worry about any checks and checkmates by
the rook by the rook and this night on
h5 we have E 4 here and the e4 was the
sealed move
so here the game was adjourned and about
when he had to make some move he played
f4 e 4 and basically tall and Koblenz I
analyzed this position entire night so
the botanique and both of them agreed
that it was a draw but what does have
the white pieces so he still decided to
play this on rook to d2 by tal king t1
now comes Rock to g2 rook to b3 King to
e7
now comes Knight to g7 and now Knight
captures and after he finally grabbing
that pawn with the idea that after rook
captures which was played in the game
now comes rook captures on g4 so
basically it all gave up a piece but he
will grab all of the pawns and now at
this point this point cannot be
protected if you try rookie 3 then you
get King f6 attack the knight Knight h5
check King to e5 Knight to g4 now
protecting the e4 pawn but now comes h5
with the threat of h4 and after your
capture it now rook captures on e4 is a
draw whether you exchange works or not
so after rook to g4 Knight to f5 check
we have King e6 Knight 2 G 3 h5 now
Knight has to capture rook captures
would check King to f2 and now King to
e5 so this is basically it's basically a
draw but you know maybe you do have a
rook and the night against the rook and
the pawn of course black black can
blunder
so King to g3 we have rook to h4 not
allowing the King to get any closer to
the pawn Knight goes to g7 rope to a for
offering a trader Brooks if tile is able
to exchange rooks then it's immediately
a draw rook to a3 and now rope to d4
preparing to meet any checks with simply
roadblocks are up to a6 roadblocks rogue
goes to a 7 now King a rook goes back
not allowing the King to go
anywhere near the pawn rook tilith's 11
now comes again rook to a for offering a
trade rook checks King goes the f6r up
to a 7 and now rogue back to e for not
allowing the king to get closer to the
pawn and also if the rope checks the
king then King takes Knight so night to
h5 check King again sex night and now
King to f3 attacking the rook rook to b3
rook to before and night the beef g3
rook to f4 check acting moves rook to f7
now we have rook to a five again rook to
f6 Knight to e4 attacking the rook rook
air-five offering a trade rook to a6
check King g7 night to g3 rock to e5
King attacks rook and now rook to b5
again not allowing the king anywhere
further further than the rank 4 then the
fourth ranked king before now king f7
Knight to f5 King checks and now Knight
blocks we have rogue back Knight to f3
and now rook checks again we have night
blocks again rugby 1 and 2 now nice the
c6 King to g6 night opens up a double
check King to h5 and now rook to a5 here
rook to e1 check King to f3 rook to f1
came to g3 and now rope to a4 and here
after so many so many attempts botanique
finally decided to accept the draw in
game 18 it doesn't really matter
rookie 7 you don't really have any
threats King will go simply go back and
there is no way for this King to
approach the position so this was game
18 I do hope you enjoyed it I will
probably cover game 19 today as well and
then tomorrow we will probably be able
to finish this very very long and very
exciting series tall versus botanique
1960 World Chess Championship match so
yeah I mean I'm planning to but I'm not
saying that I will like a hundred
percent so yeah for though I mean I
really do hope you enjoyed it and I do
hope you enjoy all the rest of the games
until the end of the series and for
those of you who are maybe new to this
channel and new to the series in the
description below you will
you will find links to check out all of
the games from this match and also I do
recommend you check out my my coverage
of the 1959 candidates tournament the
tournament McHale had to win to get this
opportunity to play against Mikhail
Botvinnik so a lot of things happening I
would like to thank Martin Thomason
damnit toilets don't do then Josh Huff
and Malcom Brown for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I will make both of them
from this match tall versus botanique
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with game 19 of the
Talbot UNIX series thank you all